how's it gonna rest this is pimp ah Wow
so we did cartoon characters in real
life we'd last one we did with Simpson I
asked you bros on Twitter many of you
selected spongebob I'm curious to see
what the [ __ ] we can make out of this
cuz I have no idea let's give it a go
see what troche it is we can make it's
really gross
this is triggering my trip of phobia man
that's [ __ ] oh so far so amazing that
honestly looked like it could be
spongebob so okay let's do the eyes
this is great terrifying as always just
what I wanted more nightmares all right
let's do the notes that's 6c as notes
looking sexy s [ __ ]
let's get those cheekbones poppin
yeah Wow duat for you so sexy sexy sexy
he's so sexy
alright let's give him that beautiful
shirt you gotta look so good speech babe
alright let's finish this [ __ ] off with
those beautiful arms whatever
that looks so good it's like bro ball
bro pants bro Bob bro pants fro Bob
broke pants bro Bob broke pants bro Bob
bro Hantz alright fine finish this [ __ ]
off with some nice aah pants girl speech
babe I imagine these are the pants
I mean if you want realism you're not
getting any further than this this is
this is Spanish babe in relief he's
really the kind of guy you don't want to
meet alone in an alleyway realism
completed
so there's two more characters that I
think would be good and that's one of
them is Squidward
let's do hat let's do handsome Squidward
should we use John Luke Picard yeah all
right
jean-luc Picard it is [ __ ] it let's get
rid of the stupid eyebrows
you
looks even handsomer Jesus Christ let's
start with those beautiful kissy lips
how are we gonna give the card car
doesn't have any lips at all this is a
huge problem
why Picard why don't you have lips and I
get to carry that when I kiss you you
look so cute now next up them cheekbones
damn
that's my cheekbone that's my cheekbone
that's my cheekbone that's my picker
cheekbone it's funny how the nose is
almost identical already Jesus Christ
yep that looks good now let's just add
the butt
oh damn that is one fine-ass looking
bull chin I didn't know you had it in
you Picard
he just looks better and better I love
it
oh oh yeah Squidward doesn't have any
ears let's get rid of this that looks so
good
that looks so great I have a crush on
senpai Squidward yay
let's finish this [ __ ] off with the ice
okay not quite the results I want damn
it
and there we have it
not quite as handsome as maybe I'd hope
for but still pretty goddamn attractive
art thank you now last but not least we
have Patrick it's probably gonna be
pretty gross I anticipate some gross
Ness
alright we're already getting places it
already looks like him there you go
it's finished
I mean that yep that looks great so good
that looks pretty [ __ ] terrifying
nice and there you have it
sorry I don't know why I said it like
that but there you have it I guess let's
see what your brothers think my couch is
better would bang good this is why I
don't do meth anymore while I'm glad I
helped you with your meth addiction
anyway that's just what I do here on
this channel if you want more of these
type of videos let me know bros and
leave a like that really helps out a lot
and I still miss Brosius that you're
watching stay awesome